l a tutti ragazzi e benvenuti a questo
nuovo video sono fa vj siccome la
l'ultima volta che ho giocato all'apt vi
è piaciuto un sacco
ho deciso di giocarla online visto che
si può giocare online invitato ciccio e
pietro insieme siamo in tre sulla
zattera sono successe roba buona visione
comunque ragazzi ho notato che questo
gioco si può fare sta cosa puoi switch
aree da maya che è una tipa a quanto
pare me sono un ragazzo ha un rasta
incredibile sempre a piedi nudi con una
fondina tipo pistola non capisco niente
al mondo
come facciamo a starci in tre susta
zattera che grossa quali sta unendo riso
ma non ci stiamo a casa
cosa ho visto per un attimo e ricca
strato in mezzo
leo caruso hai tenuto il nome vecchio
ricordo
e niente ciccio muore nei giorni e lo
spoiler
te l'ho detto che non c'è spazio e
inutile che proviamo fast and gold è
stata la puzza di qualcuno non credo sia
ciccio ma allora se livelli più tristi
cosi schifosi qua inquinato ecco tu fai
quello che recupera le 9 ok lo squalo
non lo puoi ferire perché ti serve la
roba che farai dopo recupera tutto è
possibile i barili hanno un sacco di
roba prendeteli ok
fidatevi del mio del mio conigli ma se
arriva qui lo squalo che si fa
lo squalo da ogni tanto la zattera è
stato anch'esso a piedi poi a non fare
visto che abbiamo tanto spazio
e allora non lo sono stata campo aspetta
che al barile
non l'ho preso i barili lega motivate a
prendere roba in quanto costruisco le
prime cose che tanto sono un po
squillato allora che più tardi e niente
per un attimo ha sperato ci fosse più
spazio sulla barca non sono sempre della
plastica che ha buttati venti forti di
plastica alle teen plastica non ce l'ho
io descartes 90 chiesto con forza marca
quanto possa implicare questo spazio
ancora plastica e servirebbe una roba
un'isola si è in questo gioco che
succede alla roba strana
l'isola si avvicina a te ma non è che
noi ci misuriamo il titolo è potrebbe
essere però non ho mai capito allora la
prima cosa che bisogna fare è premere il
tasto tab vedete che ci sono un sacco di
oggetti le prima cibo acqua non serve a
niente perché tanto ne siamo a digiuno
strumenti quindi il simbolo del
comunismo
avete parte lo la costruzione qualora vi
serve per fare il pubblico appena fatto
io è comunque credo che la tua storia
sia giusta siamo noi che ci avviciniamo
non è l'isola vicino ho realizzato
adesso che è un po anti fisico che
un'isola vicina
io nello scorso video detto ragazzi si
sta vicino all'unisono
ma come mi sembrava mi sa che abbiamo un
problema è non puoi farli glielo puoi
farci niente
la lancia in legno serve se tu guardi a
sinistra dell'isola c'è una zattera in
tantissimo la vedete questi punti
stabilissimo sull'isola
no è però la zattera ci serve per
muoverci perché poi con la vela ci
possiamo avere in giro che il bambino ci
conviene andiamo sul viso la famiglia
qualcuno ha lasciato no cavolo devo fare
lascia velocemente aspettando serie la
sto per fare se la corda la corda
ricavata a quanto sporco sto male su di
lui sono finiti cacciava messina arriva
arriva
ecco mi batto io vado a prendere le robe
servono forse lei poi sopravvivete li
paga
non mi abbandonate lega aiuto mi sta
raccogliendo cose che ci serve o un
rottame come hai fatto tra il rottame
home che ce n'è uno anche cielo i rotta
grandi raga un rotta i rottami servono
tantissimo alla rete sostanza un premio
in acqua e vedendo se riesco ad andare
alla zattera paga la zattera c'è un
altro lontane bis riso la parola non è
però quella in isolalta ci serve la
scala per arrivarci non abbiamo i
rottami per farla scavo meglio ce
l'abbiamo ma dobbiamo dire noi si ferma
qua la zattera non c'è un freno porca
vacca non c'aveva niente sarà la zattera
non c'è un freno alla vela che possiamo
metterli dopo guarda come si fa la vela
maracanà aver passato un barile vicine
ma siete orbi ma non ci arriva troppo
distante 4 siete scemi ma dico io a
prendere al nodo cosa allora siamo
troppo indaffarati a costruire qui cosa
cioè qua lavoriamo ho trovato un rottame
non avete idea di quanto salvano i
rottami abbiamo fatto più in dieci
secondi noi che io nello scorso video
che c'è la squadra o inesta media per
posto è più o meno su quella melma
megalodon degli scatti o prendeteli
verificati quattro barili mi aveva
dischi 4 barili li voglio tutti ragazzi
tutti li vogliono anche lo squalo tra
quello rapporti un semplice scuola va
bene allora adesso il momento di fare le
cose
io faccio del cibo voi costruita
ampliato un pò intorno se riuscite
io cuoce cuocere al lido questi una
testa velici diete 1 ecco niente
tralascia di tutte e due le mangi unendo
da iaia goro e dover dove sono io no e
mangia mangia lo ok con l'antica voce
del soprano e non ci prendono mai visto
cosa c'è là sopra per non sono mai
riuscito è andato a fare una scala puoi
fermarti apriamo sul posto schifoso
consigliamo una scala anzi se riesco a
farla vela mi avvicino io allora spetta
facile la vera vela rottami datemi il
rottame un rottame veloci veloci simili
colori con il 46
raga faccio io datevi vicino all'isola
ampi dove serve per quando non c'è vento
perché data serve dice la direzione del
20 st gioco niente abbiamo perso il
pagaia note pagaia era capo c'è una
patata ma allora ora ci serve las quanti
rottami avete ancora dietro due perfetto
e ai due rottami quindi facciamo questa
cosa aspetta la plancia con la lancia
mai 4 cosa ha fatto cose 4 bravissimo
diciamo qualcosa io faccio la scala tre
secondi abbiamo fatto quello che nella
tua vita non sollecita a noi bulloni
servono perso schifo come si fanno i
bulloni porca vacca sua sbagliato no ok
ci lasciano ciò che porta ok siamo
arrivati perfetto fatta la scala gira
avvicinati avvicinate con avvicinano
l'hack è male
bravo ancora che lo conosce lo sa
no del cerri prima messa verrà tra
scarica è troppo bassa molto ma non non
rischio arrivarci da parker è stata la
facciata e arriviamo alla parte piccola
questa roba che c'è una pagaia cosa
praticamente sto arrivando all'isola di
nuovo da solo quasi finito la pagaia
dobbiamo sfruttare per che l'h devo
avvicinarmi non ci arrivo ci arriva per
un niente vi serata la sua gaia non ci
arrivo per nulla sono riusciti a salire
su riuscito a salire per mesi in gol chi
sta prendendo i costi to face che io
prendo i cocchi fa il depuratore
dell'acqua al depuratore dell'acqua fa
le cifre tutti bordo dell'auto ha
proposto questo io sto prendendo roba
qua mangia e bevi fai cose se non metti
il fuoco sotto il pesce così cuoci il
legno ma ti sei scemo faccio io rega ma
il suo il depuratore dell'acqua allora
vi dovete fare solo la tazza vuota
raga arrivo è ma facciamo un contenitore
bello grosso e lì ci mettiamo tutte le
provviste va bene e sto
cos'è questo film stranissimo un
inventario o un antenna progetto
ricevitore tu hai progetto antenne a
queste cose servono per trarsi in salvo
però ci metteremo un botta farò ragazze
poi però che c'è loro pasto nissim a a
sinistra c'è una cosa una nave cucina
erano alla zattera
no non è una zattera cos'è una roba nel
buio occhio ragazzi ci siamo io ho
girato già avete la pagaia no bara ci
giocherò riprendere devi prendere in
cima c'è un coso dovere di prendere ci
sei qui rendilo si in cima prendi l'ho
preso
successo e cioè no no no no no perché no
[Risate]
[Musica]
grazie quando mi ricordo un oro rosso
quando ha messo la musica perché sa bene
che non capitola sopra e facendo si può
cioè se nel corpo da voi che stava
annegando
i ragazzi spero che il primo episodio
secondo però il primo online di raft vi
sia piaciuto del prossimo episodio
amplieremo un po la zona cercheremo di
fare robe più fighi ea me sta facendo
veramente un botto e penso anche ai
ragazzi quindi ragazzi spero che mi stai
facendo anche voi come se ce lo cerca
per società iniziali sono stati così di
schede da via
[Musica]